uh hello everybody
um thank you for being here
if you have any questions
um please feel free to just
ask your like raise your hand or if you
sit in the front please just stop start
talking loud
um
and unless it will become too disturbing
I think that's totally fine and it won't
be a problem
or you can also put it in slido if you
if you want to be anonymous we can also
do that yeah
simultaneously yeah
yeah
so
this is about Ensemble programming also
known as small programming who of you
has already heard about mob programming
before
thank you and and who of you has maybe
practiced it before
I'm so nice so we do have some people
who already know it that's great that's
a start
um so
on summer programming is this thing that
starts feeling really slow
and then it gets it really speeds up as
the team gets better in the on summer
program what we are doing is we are
working on the same code at the same
time we are serving as a group with many
people we are solving the same problem
at the same computer
and this works uh as seen on the picture
sitting in the same room but it also
works even remotely yeah so there are
several ways how people do this and
people do this successfully it it's sort
of it's a fun way to work it it can also
if the team is good it can be very
efficient
and it it makes it takes a lot of
pressure uh it makes a lot of pressure
for doing a high quality sort of thing
yeah a high quality code
um like I come from very my background
is very open source and async that's
where I spend most of my life working
where it takes one month to review some
PR so for me Ensemble programming is the
opposite of that it's like the best way
to create the team and maximize the flow
of everybody is on the same screen
working at the same time that's why I
love Ensemble programming for maximum
flow
yeah
exactly so we're eliminating all the
wait time
what do you think why would some people
do something this stupid and pay five
times
the money for the same work
do you have any opinions on that
please uh
you don't need code reviews later you
just have it on the fly so you actually
saves some time at least very maybe yeah
maybe not five types of the time but
that's something yes so with this group
I think they have sort of like three
code reviews going on at the same at the
same time yeah
and defeat and the feedback is coming
immediately and you're building the
feedback as it's coming in yeah very
cool this there may be another opinion
on why why we want would be like to why
we would want to do something like this
yes please
together directly exactly maybe
different people have different ideas or
different uh or or are an expert in a
different field and they have Bring It
On a different level of knowledge that
can be incorporated into the solution
related to that also there might be two
or three different ways of doing the
same thing and you might want to talk
about together the pros and cons of each
approach and then choose the one which
is the most appropriate in that moment
or maybe try them all that too or maybe
try see which one breaks
yes exactly so we so so we we create a
shared understanding of how we are
building things like how we make design
decisions and how we write code maybe
different teams have different sorts of
of guidelines in this and working as a
mob we can align our understanding how
we want to do that what do you mean we
already have a knowledge base of like
100 pages that shows our common
understanding there I read it every day
come on nobody reads that nobody reads
that
um if requirements are unclear that gets
exposed quickly
yeah and sometimes you have a client in
your mob as well so you got client
review at the same time
yeah so it's a great way to get Junior
developers started on larger projects
yeah completely agree I have not seen
any way uh any technique working better
for onboarding new Junior people other
than more programming it's it's really
the best way
think any other comments
uh one quick oh sorry
you maybe don't need stack Overflow that
much because somebody in the room knows
the answer
maybe not that much but maybe you still
want to use it if if nobody knows the
answer or maybe you use Google or
chatgpt or whatever
everybody in the room knows the answer
not just the person who Googled it
because everybody Googled it and the
interesting thing is when when when when
you're working uh and and when you're
currently typing and and figuring
something out maybe some somebody in the
mob is already starting the research and
as you're getting there you already have
the answer then it's a little might be a
little bit sooner
um
I can imagine that it's a more efficient
way to um
uh I can't imagine that it's a more
efficient way of spreading uh the
development culture uh I mean we heard
earlier that culture beats uh policy
every day
very good thank you
yeah I think there was one more hand
there
that could be the last comment Maybe
um yeah so that to get everybody
familiar with the solution so for future
work everyone's on the same page of like
why this bit of code is there or what
these lines mean because everyone helped
to make the solution
yeah I agree
so it seems like Ensemble programming uh
works pretty well for some teams maybe
not for other teams but it it has
happened to work out pretty well and
that's why we would like to actually try
that and we want to be one big one big
ensember
and for that I would I I need you or at
least come come further to the front
seats so I I need some people filling
the seeds in the front so please stand
up now
they are some everybody stand up
everybody stand up please row zero here
and and take take some seats here yeah
don't don't worry it will be fine don't
no need to be afraid
yeah we also can use the row zero
they're right in the front
there's also
if you are very current courageous also
take a seat in the in the front row
otherwise we will just like you use
people whoever are here
they have a few seats right in the front
yeah so it would be awesome if you if
you have the courage to come in in the
front too it would be awesome thank you
thank you
so the way this works first of all
understand here
as a principal
um we want to be very patient with each
other we want to be kind we will treat
each other with consideration and
respect and it is perfectly fine to not
know something or to do something wrong
it's perfectly fine to make mistakes
here okay we are not laughing at anybody
and we will slow down for even the
slowest person so we are just here to
learn and we want to support each other
that's that's a principle that's the
main principle
um and the way this will work
um we will be standing like three people
we are standing now so there'll be a
person talking into the mic on this side
the person typing like I'm typing now
and where ADI standing will be the next
person this person will be already
getting used to the stage and in five
minutes we will change this will the
person standing here will become the
tightest yeah I will start speaking and
then Greg will sit down
that's how we're gonna do it
but the next person needs needs to also
be able to see the screen so if if you
want to stand some somewhere there maybe
so you can see the screen that might be
better
um and this is the first part we're only
going to do it for one hour no more yeah
and that'll be a second part we're gonna
do the small ensembles in the second
part smaller and they'll be facilitated
um
okay
before that who wants to be the the
third person I won't be the third one so
yeah actually we will start just
grabbing paper from the first row okay
and it's fine yeah
um just like in Circus Hi Felix
so Felix you would be the first person
um talking so you would actually come
come to my place
yeah
and then you would be the first person
typing Thomas
hi Thomas
and and can you please come around to
left side and
now uh I would I would like to ask you
to to keep rotating if that's possible
yeah to to fill in the seeds
[Laughter]
there's a laptop yeah awesome so we want
to keep rotating yeah when every five
minutes we will be rotating
a different person will be typing a
different person will be talking and we
need to rotate the seeds Okay so so more
people keep coming
um
when you are typing
you are on the keyboard
and but you're not supposed to make any
decision or think too much I mean yes of
course you have to think because you
will be typing and typing is not that
easy but the person that is talking will
make the decisions the person that is
talking has to finally say of what we're
gonna do
and maybe the person that is talking has
no idea what we should do next maybe
they they are completely overwhelmed
with this exercise
might happen and that's that's totally
fine that's totally fine if a person
talking doesn't have any idea
maybe just ask the Ensemble hey maybe
anybody has an idea
and then maybe somebody raises a hand
and then and then we have an idea and
then we can try that and if you sit here
in The Ensemble and you have an idea
just raise your hand maybe the Navigator
will ask you maybe not it's up to them
to choose you know but just if you have
an idea just raise your hand it'd be
nice to see
yeah
do you have any questions regarding this
process
yes please can you bring the mic to him
please
I mean not a question but I would just
like to point out it might be a little
chaos for everyone to keep Shifting the
seats so maybe they can just get up in
their own seats and then come to the
stage uh directly rather than Shifting
the seats with yes it might become chaos
and we will see how it turns out and
then maybe we'll do some continuous
improvement in our process and wreck
this out yeah a python joke in there
good one
cool
yes
what do what do I need to talk about
maybe somebody has an idea
yep so I have a task list
of course we have an exercise and I will
read the description of the exercise
here so the title of our tutorial is
data validation with pedantic so there's
a bit of data read the data from a CSV
which is a normal data science task and
to check the data is valid and then
return a list of pedantic typed objects
of the valid
entries in that file this data is about
houses
so we have ID we have columns like ID
Street here the house was built number
of fireplaces in the house that's very
important when I buy a house how many
fireplaces it has you know the quality
of the fireplaces first floor square
feet and second floor square feet
and there's some constraints here that
ID has to be an integer
straight column has to be the string the
house has to be between 1700 1900 we
don't want any of these new build houses
the first floor is at least one third of
the second floor so it's a bit like this
or like it's a reasonable house
and the four fireplace quality has to be
part of the this enum excellent good
okay I don't know what J means but CA
fair and poor
when there's some bonus questions as
well in the end
so we're gonna use this programming
environment called gitpod.io which is
very easy to set to start just a
browser-based IDE
um yeah which already has a task list in
it so this is a task list which we'll be
following
and there's one more component the mob
timer
this will timer will buzz every five
minutes and tell us to switch
so I'm just gonna start it now
start should we start yes maybe let's
let's get our poker to the mic and our
typist to the keyboard
was it yes and first get used to again
not to use it
which one was it already
three fingers to slide to the other side
ah yep if you click Start turn okay and
now I got then I go back to this okay
that was my question where was the ID
okay
okay first of all let's look at the task
list
um okay does this mean this writing test
is already written can we can we look
that up where that is
yeah sorry yeah yeah I think here
okay this is validate and we have test
validate can you look into the test
validate
Okay so
okay here we see okay so so these are
already done okay okay can we go back to
the task list
yeah how do we run the test first okay
yeah I think it just ran already but we
can
try to yes there is something red in the
bottom do you see what it what it reads
yeah so it says we we have a one type
error
so we have we just got a non-type which
has no length which is obviously bad uh
can we see which line it is seven okay
so we're trying to get
1460 rows out of this CSV so first of
all we have to read the CSV
I think
oh no we're reading it yep
yes exactly
so go to the definition yes we are okay
so any suggestions on how we should read
the CSV
all right
yeah there's a raised hand over there
first by parameterizing the file that we
want to read
okay let's
yeah yeah up front here
from the read CSV functions
we might want to check what the return
type is likely to be maybe it's it looks
like a panda State the frame but maybe
it's deceptive
um yeah that that's a good argument yeah
let's see what we're trying to get here
in the second test
it looks like
with just some sort of yeah
I think there was something in the task
list what the return type might be
that's a good good idea let's see
um
we start from from the top to the bottom
and in line two there is this one row it
already has a check mark because it's
already done yeah and then we are now
currently we're in line three and we
want to work work our way to the bottom
or line by line okay
yeah so it it seems we're
is anyone has an idea what we're trying
to create here
we'll let the test pass that's the
second task so at the moment the test is
failing and we have to make sure it
passes anyway
I mean more in the sense of which data
type we want to get
yeah right here
to me it looked very like we want to
return a pandas data frame
uh yeah where do you see that
well in the in line 12 it uses
df.columbs dot values which would work
on a panda State office so so that's at
least an option but I mean there's other
libraries that could also be the DF with
this value
could we take a look at the Imports in
the files if maybe
there's already a specification
yeah we can look into the requirements
in our requirements txt
since we pandas okay
let's let's try to get get upon us uh
data frame out of there
so
uh yeah I mean yeah import pandas and
let's just
try to
write to read CSV method
what should Imports be to our read CSV
method anyone has an idea yeah
okay then let's add a variable for the
path
and let's yeah add
yeah let's import pandas as PD as we
usually do and here you're in the front
yeah I was just not to I would not
change the signature of this function
because this would make the tests fail I
think so we should stick with the
signature but rather maybe make it
constant in the in the fight or
somewhere
okay
what was that sound yeah yeah should we
switch around where do I go uh sorry um
maybe you heard the sound and the sound
means that we want to rotate so whoever
was sitting here I think that's you
welcome Simon
um you will be the next person typing so
I I would like to you like take some
seat I don't know maybe maybe further in
in the back you will become the next
person talking and you will be the next
person typing and that's and that's the
way we have Round of Applause please for
the people
thank you
and also what is important when we
rotate we want to keep working on the
intent of the previous of the previous
talker so whatever he was doing and
deciding we want to keep doing that so
we don't want one to shift Focus every
rotation right we want to keep doing
what we are doing now
yeah
thank you
yes that's a very good idea we want to
start the timer so can you please open
up that window and click on start turn
and then you can go back to the thank
you
uh higher the question actually you said
so you wanted to keep this
you said you wanted to keep the
signature as it is
um I actually don't work as a data
scientist but devops and I like
dependency injection and maintainable
code and I wonder why do you want this
to be static maybe I don't see something
uh no I would just like to stick to the
task the task is to make the first test
pass and not to adjust it and that first
test uses the real CSV function without
any parameter okay that's the only
intention
I'm not strongly opinionated
uh yeah so um I will keep this advice
and then so we are not changing the
signature please remove my beautiful CSV
pass thank you and now we can go back to
test validates and set it so this is
um
quick suggestion
um we are python we can do both we can
just make it a standard value a default
value parameter true story
um
you know is it
can someone tell us a path okay it's
okay yeah it's okay yeah
okay and now
question is a test running every time we
make a change here seems so
yes we we are using something called Pi
test watch and every time we change a
file it runs the tests
okay so thank you so we see it's still
failing we still have no lengths of
course we don't get the data somehow so
we need to change the he has a read CSV
method and we want to actually with open
a video read I never use pandas thank
you
sorry
do you need some parameters for CSV here
or just the default ones
okay
mm-hmm
and now
yeah yeah written thank you
yes
thank you
we always celebrate green bar
the number one rule
so next one is and skip the failing test
for column names just a second can we
stick with the one before
um we are creating a new code base would
be really cool if you start with typins
right away
please like it yeah so please yeah
can we say that the pandas a little
frame or
ah okay
yes we can with that picky who is for a
string of our past whisper buff here
it's not enough
string is good
okay good
next okay so yeah we were testing the
columns I saw him and keeps failing just
for girls name okay three fingers I
heard yes oh yeah
[Music]
We are failing okay oh
and what is the next one so after
unskipping
on the task list
what does it say
do we need to fix it as well
make the test pass yes so we need to fix
it
[Applause]
so I don't know
so
we need to check the list
um so to me it looks like we are loading
too many columns so we get more columns
than we expect
thank you
[Applause]
we need one more person
you're the typist yeah
I mean whoever wants to skip it can also
skip it that's okay and
it's a question
yeah this is
right yeah
but if somebody really wants please come
here and sit somewhere in the front and
then you will be
able to do it yeah
are you guys ready yeah awesome so so
please start the timer and then go back
to the
yeah okay I think so I agree with you I
think it looks like we return too much
data
so I would look into how we could drop
those columns or maybe prevent to read
them in the first place
party know about an argument to only
read the subset of columns in CSV
is talking right now is very nice
talking on the level of intention
and then the typist maybe that attackers
know how to do this do you know how to
do this yes
so yeah maybe we should take the list of
those columns
and save it somewhere as a constant in
this validate.pi file
and
um I just like to point out something so
this is like it's just a subset of the
complete data frame that we want so
maybe we can just check for subset
rather than checking for yeah to me in
the test it looks like we have extra
items in the left set so I assume that
we just dropped them
if you have more questions you can also
put it on the sliders
[Music]
in the output of income
um you could already hit classes
[Applause]
you could already drop or you can
already select follow columns while
reading the CSV can you do that how how
is it possible just adding the keyword
arguments columns equals and then the
list
thank you use calls
um yeah I think setting columns our
rights The Columns are reading yeah so
but at least I just want to say that we
are doing tdd really well right now
we're doing refactoring on green so I
test the green and now we're improving
our code so yeah yeah it passed awesome
okay let's look at the next task
okay we should create the data object
from detect from addict
so let's check out this test the test
create valid house
three fingers yeah
okay so there is the function create
house
and we already have the dict
and
can we look at the test as well
trying
oh
okay and what happens
so to me it looks like
house is already created
what is fantastic house
it's coming from validate
ah
can we look at the task once again
okay
yeah so we should add new um checks to
this task to this is this done I would
say we have read it and we have so we
saw that it only tests for one of the
properties
so we should add another assert which
checks the ID field for the value one
perfect
and now I would say we go to the house
class definition and at the field here
as well
and if I remember correctly it is an
integer as well
awesome
[Applause]
so yeah I think we can already check
this task off
oh yeah okay we were ahead of ourselves
a bit one by one I had more tests for
each field okay let's enter the fields
and switch
okay as we're switching I have a
piece of advice for the Navigator when
you see people raise their hands you
don't have to hear them it's only if you
want to you can like ask them to speak
it's all for you for you now
okay let's go
okay so there are three more fields to
add
so that's
yes we could make three assertions first
in in the test validate
so that would be the house.street
I think with the capital
C is equal equal sesame
uh
and we could we could uh make the test
pass first
it gets us more Applause
[Applause]
and well yeah first then now first floor
what is what was it was it square feet
and that looks like an integer yeah
uh yeah oh gosh how was the uh oh yeah
thank you
[Music]
oh gosh because it's not a let me check
the task list
this is and fireplace Cube
you could not
wait what's the fireplace in the in the
example house
fireplace zero fireplace quality none
okay
that's an integer what
okay and assert
house.fireplace queue
and I would recommend here to use the is
none
um
any any other opinions on that
and I have no idea what the data type of
the fireplace quality should be
oh here's here's a subject can can I get
your suggestion please
I think
strings okay great uh any second opinion
yeah or here was one at the front
optional string I would use optional
string for now because they don't say
anything about
um it's it's optional with a capital O
validation
was it options round bracket
square bracket Str
ah
can you check the task again because I
think in the introduction it said
somewhere that it's a an enum set
where is he where's the
introductions come later let's just do
optional string for now yeah my task
task list here we have lots of this this
creates room for debate uh can we hear
Fabian please and then
no I just want to mention that since 310
you can use the pi parameter to make
either none or string which I really
love and yes it saves me so much yes
because then we are restricting
ourselves to some python version I don't
know whether that's a good idea do we
want that that's do we specify a python
version anywhere here
so that's that's an interesting call
yeah does the does the the optional
string work
what is fireplace let's go for for
optional string for now they we and and
someone else needs to take care of the
enum thing I I haven't I haven't got it
yet
yeah so shall we check it as done if
they know the test doesn't pass yet no
how
[Music]
um yeah there's there's one or here in
the back sorry
oh so from typing import optional
thanks
what's going on
what was that the beep
[Applause]
so okay you can go to the
next the top next to it and start the
turn
okay
so
we need one more person to me
okay data object with first floor and
second for footage
so write a failing test for creating
house
with the first floor equal to 100
so we go to
test validate and we Define a new test I
would say
uh
I know this is not Windows I hope this
works
I think you have to command history um
problem
so what's in our data the test
uh write a film test for creating hours
with first floor
102 how should we call the test
test okay
test
[Music]
create first floor yeah first first of
all
let's say
where's that let's go
so yeah so the
mm-hmm
and that's about the
first floor checking so we have to check
we have to assert that the first floor
or
is 100
awesome
but we have to make it fail
as far as understood
thank you
done
yeah
okay
okay can we mark this is done everybody
agrees yes
It's tricky to add it to the house class
and it starts with a non-letter
character yeah
we can also check this as done
in the US class use pedantic field Alias
function to give it a valid name okay
let's I I am not familiar with the
pedantic soul
[Music]
does anyone have an idea how to
um use this field at Alias for first
floor maybe the driver has an idea
no he doesn't
sorry I didn't ask first so the idea is
basically that you can give it a valid
name not starting with a number and then
exactly as you're using it you can
specify an alias which is the name it
expects when it Imports so that it
creates this instance just uh let's say
like this
yeah just
first yeah perfect
before anyone gets any ideas
so we can just exactly just
substitute this
um it almost worked
now
just a quick hint you're missing the
type annotation though for this field
still okay let's let's take care of it
um
um I don't know how to
okay the
double quote the double
or maybe
sorry
yes
double
what to say column
and then
[Music]
let's try yeah
no we we have a problem name our name
field is not defined so probably we have
to import it
uh does anyone know okay maybe they're
from there yeah try it's identity import
field okay looks good
[Applause]
yeah okay
thank you
um sorry sorry I I would like to
interrupt this now because I think that
you have all now seen how this works and
I would like before we do smaller groups
I would like to do a little retro review
like talk about how this went so and the
first questions I have for you is
how did that feel
maybe you want to answer
you can also
as a typist you can also put it on
slider if you want to say
uh I mean in the beginning it felt uh
kind of that we were very small steps
um because people have different Focus
uh on different topics that
um was kind of bumpy but it got faster I
think in uh over time
thank you thank you
yeah Christian
so one one thing that I noticed that is
that is what is very very strange here
in this uh in especially in the talking
seat
is that half of your brain capacity is
left for thinking about the code and the
other half is uh is communicating and
when you program all on your own you you
don't have that
is it good or is it bad
[Laughter]
so for me it felt like my hand was
forced because we have the task list
that we normally don't have
what I noticed is like how important is
the driver's role in this because I felt
like the person on the Green Jacket like
maybe you have done before this that you
were really specific in giving
instructions to the group and also
ignoring the group if you felt like this
is best for you too and when this was
not the case then the whole thing slowed
down and went a bit more chaotic so like
this is if you're more used to it as a
group and as a driver it really helps a
lot like a good typist makes a
difference
like they're
I I I confused you with the words like
the person talking is sometimes called
the Navigator and the person typing is
called the driver that's that's the
Navigator it's best when if two people
know what they're doing that's best if
at least one person knows that they're
doing that's okay and it both like that
gets difficult yeah
yeah I think especially if somebody does
not know does not yet know how it works
it's very easy for the others to just
say yeah do it like this
um and then just forget that the person
might still need some explanation
so that knowledge sharing actually
happens and not just you get working
code but still only one person knows why
it works and then five minutes later
that person who was typing becomes their
talking person so they now they have to
ask questions so they're forced to learn
in that role
thank you
something I
something I find super important is that
you are actually not alone there yeah
that it's very very different from for
example live coding and teaching where
you usually know your stuff inside out
but here you don't so
um this would be super scary being there
yeah I found it awesome that we can draw
from all the knowledge of all the people
for example with these use calls so
normally you would have to switch to the
documentation
and yeah using this method to not
necessarily you don't have to do it
thank you yeah I mean use calls it has
no underscore even it's from like 10
years ago by this okay
so so I did this I think three times uh
on my own with uh with left and with a
smaller group at an event
and what we are doing here is so far the
best solution maybe this is because we
have such a big audience we've had a lot
of ideas which was interesting to me
yeah okay let's go to next yeah uh what
did you learn
that we have to learn about pedantic
so I'm I'm using
um pedantic at work and uh but this this
field thing I haven't used before I saw
it this this
somewhere in the morning session from
Alex upstairs
it was really interesting to see the
communication happening like sometimes
you just like change this and then it's
like no in the other file and it's like
no in the test and like it's super nice
like we can use line numbers or
something like that but we need to be
very concise and also calm like I think
that was that was cool to see and how it
can be improved
you can post it also on slido just so
that I can also read that out if you
don't want to talk
so this is going to be the last comment
I guess for this
yeah like like my previous person uh the
communication is exercised very well
um and um especially when you're in the
driver's seat
um you
um you gotta get away from that I do
everything my way but uh
in order to preserve the well feeling in
the team
um to do it our way
so whatever your coding style is or
whatever you have to do it our way
yeah thank you like I see more
programming as communication skills
training like you have to defend your
ideas you have to disagree with other
people's ideas and I like doing it
better when it's live in front of the
screen rather than GitHub comments
that's my preference and somehow I
learned my teammates better when I
program with them compared to playing
some online games with them that's like
I know how they think I know how they
type you know and I feel much more
connected to them as programmers
are you saying you're working as an
actual team
okay just to plug in if anyone is
tweeting please hashtag pycon D and Pi
data but then
yeah just yeah I'm very late on Twitter
so yeah sorry is there anything on slido
or can we close the Retro just want to
see if there's anything on slider no did
anybody put anything on slider
no okay
you want to speak
I think for a group this large we need
kind of a better tooling for the raising
hands and stuff because I was like
sitting here like five minutes and the
mic was somewhere
right there and yeah
so it's it's uh okay in smaller groups I
think but thanks you wanted to
contribute more from the mob yeah I I'm
sorry about that we are Breaking All the
Rules here so it's it's kind of hard but
I I think it's it worked quite well so
yeah and the best way to talk is to come
here and talk for five minutes
[Laughter]
uh question is there a recommended size
for uh for this Ensemble programming
um the way I usually see it is between
three and five people maybe more but um
uh the bigger the group gets or the
harder it is to manage or to keep in or
to stay in the flow actually I'm
surprised how will it worked with this
large audience I'm really surprised
you are doing really well
[Applause]
yeah so oh yeah there's one more hand
actually I don't know before we move
yeah
uh one one more question regarding to
that so
you said about the team signs that it's
quite limited but also I would imagine
that the time that you're able to
actually do that in real life would be
limited in terms of that your company
allows for that can you have like a
rough estimation how often you actually
get to do that and also what is your
changing interval or do you do the
changing also in in real life with the
three to five people and how long would
that be thank you
I am aware of teams that work
exclusively this way and and for some of
them it works out really successful
um
like compared to teams who do peer
programming exclusively like in peer
programming you have to be active all
the time maybe it's more intense in a
mob you have sort of have time to lean
back maybe and or to order to relax a
bit so maybe it's easier to keep
throughout to to stay up throughout the
day but also I'm aware of teams that
start in the morning
and then in the middle of the day they
split up work on their own or maybe they
just have uh scheduled blocks of two to
three hours where they do more
programming maybe two or three times a
week
so there are different models whatever
works for you
um
is fine
yeah that's a good question so the
question was about the the interval
between changing driver and and
Navigator so the thing is
um you want to you want people to stay
engaged like let's say if you have a
group of five people and you're rotting
every 10 minutes it means that
um it will take a long time for you to
to be in a driver's seat again and you
you don't want to have people wait for
so long and it's it's hard to keep your
attention
um so you it's it's better to have in
the bigger the mob gets it's it's better
to have shorter timers
um you can go all the way down to two
minute rotations
and you can go all the way up to 10 and
or 15 minute rotations
um and some for some some teams they
even they have a different
um
a different time for rotating the typist
then rotating the uh talking person so
there are like people experimenting all
kinds of ways of do it of doing it and
you I think again you have to uh find
out what works best in your environment
yeah I I think I want to close the Retro
now and move on to part two there'll be
more time for questions after the second
part so just or you can also write it on
slider and I can pass them
so part two is small ensembles
so we're going to split up into 20 maybe
10 Ensemble now which will be small and
we'll be working on the same beautiful
pedantic data validation problem in in
them
the one thing which we need for this
ensembles to work is facilitators
so I saw some of you raise your hands
that you're already familiar with more
programming maybe you've done it before
so if you is anybody here willing to
facilitate an ensemble for three or four
people I see one hand two hand three
hands four
okay so we have four facilitators
um nice
the
how do you want to do it so how do you
want to do it to have four four
facilitators and we can we can also fill
up and and then B2 so we have at least
six and maybe we will find more yeah if
there is a change of mind in five
minutes
yeah there's a good question
facilitator is the person who makes sure
the timer is started when the turn
starts it's very easy to forget that
when a beep goes out people actually
switch
that's that's your job and if the person
who's supposed to be talking starts
typing you tell them like no that's not
your role keep talking if the typist
says like no I don't want to do this I
don't want to do it my way and starts
typing run away typist it's called they
say no no please you know like
collaborate with the talker this kind of
thing this basic housekeeping of the
format because once you think about the
code it's speaking human language then
you forget about more programming so
it's a simple housekeeping yeah like
that
and please make sure that people uh stay
nice with each other and if you you
notice that sort of a discussion is
going on and people can't agree maybe
tell them just to try one of those
things and stop discussing yeah
yeah bias to action we call it just try
all the things and so even in the small
ensembles the COC applies the code of
conduct so yeah
yeah like to be specific
so what's the ideal number of group uh
like the three to five people plus one
facilitator but if you only have six
facilitators so far yeah it would be
like this if more people want to
facilitate that's even better yeah I
hear more people raising their hands to
facility awesome yeah
oh
so you will need one person's laptop to
type it and there is a GitHub repo and
gitbot this web-based browser which you
can open and set up
so yeah we have something yeah so we
need you to form groups now like groups
of of of three to five people yeah we've
had one one at least one laptop so at
most one laptop
so the facilitators can stand over there
so that it's easy to
okay
[Music]
and we can just them whenever they sit
down is in the farm when they find out
how they want to see it okay I'll just
go from book to group and ask them okay
who is facilitating
[Music]
um
that's it and then I don't think we have
to do anything
awesome I'm really happy how it's going
yeah
[Music]
so
yeah they're moving the trucks already
yeah
[Music]
okay sorry yeah
wow hello I would like to ask you for
your attention at the moment does every
group have a facilitator
yes okay cool so now the first step is
to clone the repo and you I want you to
choose the right repo the one in
pre-talks is not the right repo the
correct repo is here with this QR code
so don't use the one in pre-talk that
uses DBT and you know this is a python
conference we don't use DBT here
can you people here
uh so sorry there's a quick announcement
so can you please all
yeah so please go to this GitHub repo
called real estate Kata slash real
estate by dantikata don't go to tmylk
anything like this and click on the
button open in gitpod that will open you
the IDE
[Music]
a okay so
I see that some of you already have
their gitbot open so the next step the
setup is to set up the mob timer
so I suggested to go to mobtime.fly.dev
and if you go to that website
mobtime.fly.f you can create your team
some announcement like there just
telling
some details like you have the report
right yeah and yeah the real estate
Okay so
last question before we start who needs
help setting up the mob timer to add
yourself to yourself raise your hand if
you need help with the mob timer
facilitator you're responsible for this
timer that's your main thing cool thank
you
you can use it yeah just use the phone
that's fine
just like the water might be hard to
remember
but
[Music]
okay
yeah yeah
hello hello one note about the time
keeping excuse me please
before we go into the break so uh
give me a second so this we have this
room until 17 15. that's our tutorial is
here for a while
and you can stay here until that time
about to break that's up to you our
suggestion is for you to have a small
retro now in your small group and then
have a break at 15 35 for 10 minutes for
the whole conference so you can go out
of the room and then come back and
continue working in your small room in
the same space that's our suggestion the
questions for the Retro are first how
did that feel
and secondly what did you learn
have a break I'm done
we have some questions before the break
so there is a retrograde you can check
the questions here you can't see I guess
but
[Music]
hello everyone uh just quickly there's
going to be a break at 15 30 until 15 45
you can take the break or you don't need
to take the break but before you go into
the break uh I just want to also thank
the speakers again the presenters
because yeah
and yeah and you can come back and
continue with your teams so and some
people are also only for the first one
so they can also leave yeah so thank you
[Music]
foreign
if anyone is attending the social event
and they want their wristbands or the
the entry ones please do collect them
thank you